okay how about the religious schools in
Israel that actually tell people that we
should kill all Arabs and these you know
all those Jews that are running around
bombing everywhere around the world no
it doesn't [__] exist it's only in
Islam defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma neumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins cogit packed
with immune boosting properties cogit
has been scientifically proven to
promote respiratory Health aiding in
oxygen absorption while also making the
body infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the new
outbreak this winter don't forget to use
my discount code Ali da for 15% off
enjoy brothers and sisters and dear
friends it's been a long time since I've
been doing reaction video with M great
stuff M it's always a pleasure to have
you here somebody sent me this video
from the PPD postcast P Patrick pet
David and this guy I didn't know this
fliff and weasel uh was Pro Israeli so
he makes some statements we're going to
watch this guy called Adam his name is
yeah his name is yeah this guy is a
absolute dirt bag but anyways let's
watch for our you want to see it let's
see what he has to see the countries
that are succeeding the qataris even the
Saudis these days they're coming into
the modern world they're leaving the the
sixth Century mentality behind and say
let's get into the 21st century where
they need to succeed in whether it's
Gaza or whether it's Lebanon or whether
it's Syria or whether Afghanistan they
need to focus on GDP not gdt gross
domestic product not gross domestic
terrorism what bro it's it's Rich coming
from this a son of a that's what he is
this this this guy's a bastard one sec
second escalated quickly yeah yeah he's
he's he's an outright bastard yeah let
me tell you why yeah he's talking about
let's leave that sixth Century thing
behind well you bastard you are you are
a Zionist if you believe in a Holy
Scripture that's told you then leave
your 2,000 plus BC mentality behind and
stop telling the gazans and the
Palestinians that this land belongs to
you you fool if the argument you're
using is don't use the sixth Century
Islam you're basically saying you're
using your religion yeah perver you
using a perverted way cuz you know the
real Jews who wait for the Messiah do
not believe in the state you're using
that then we should use the same
argument against you am I wrong exactly
and then it's US GDP Etc terrorism how
dare you bro this guy this gu this
people this Rich coming from it's
unbelievable bro this is this is crazy I
mean this is this is talking about
terrorism bro this is ridiculous bro who
why ask you who has carried out the most
atrocities in the past 100 years please
mention a few please yeah I mean you
know when we speak just we had a call
even recently and the guy was mentioning
oh why is it that Muslims why is it
Muslims kill people Ines and all of this
like these people are simply are they
are they ignorant of okay America
dropping nuclear bombs on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki killing and Israel has dropped
three times that amount in Gaza look
look not only that of course yeah but
not only that when we look at Hiroshima
Nagasaki okay forget that let's put that
to the side we look at World War II all
all of the deaths in World War II let's
let's put that to the side no problem
let's put the American invasion of
Afghanistan Vietnam Iraq hundreds of
thousands of children hundreds of
thousand of children dead in Iraq right
and then we have videos uh of of
officials at the time saying you know uh
you know speaking about it in a way Dage
it's it's absolutely ridiculous the way
that some of these people speak about
this from an Islamic perspective the
killing of any innocent people is a very
it's a serious thing if a person kills a
person unjustly in Islam in inoc you
know like how Allah subhana tala
expresses it in the that a person
killing a person you know without any
right without any any right to do so Etc
is as if they've killed all of humanity
who was this addressed to who was this
as if they've killed all of humanity who
was this addressed one second B is who
are these individuals these zionists who
are the ones who are outright seeing
yeah we don't believe the kids are
innocent systematically on all levels
bro I mentioned this quote multiple
times because it's so references it's so
important bro can you imagine Al in any
Muslim country you have Muslim country
have Muslim country right by for the vi
re by way Imagine A Member of Parliament
from a Muslim country saying the
children of X Y and Z Place brought it
upon themselves M benari she's part of
the Israel can the Israeli she's a
member of parliament in Israel and she
literally said the children of Gaza
brought it upon themselves and what
about the the the Ambassador zippi I
mean like you have well she's basically
calling for the final solution which
Hitler mentioned you
you have them speaking so boldly uh
without fear of any consequence exactly
let's carry on listen to this flipping
weasel bastard yeah let's listen to what
he escalation quickly put the guns down
put the Quran down actually start living
by the words that the Quran says not
some false uh equivalent of what they
think is actually going on there you
talk about the genocide in Israel or in
Gaza as if it's just a matter of fact
well let let me let me show some stats
for you because after you see these
stats Israel is the worst genocide ever
the numbers according to the world data
if you trust data between 1990 and 2022
the Palestinian population overall went
from 2 million to 5 million okay pretty
bad at genocide if that's what's
happening right there in Gaza it went
from 645,000 to 2.1 million it's 3x that
a genocide to me now to 20,000 people
30,000 people needlessly killed during
this [__] war that was started by
amas is that horrible 1 million per and
any Jew or any Israel give me that
number again 600,000 to what 645,000 to
2.1 million this is in 1990 to 2022 you
know they increased cuz they're having
babies like crazy no you see this is how
in how how like when you watch thata
while being uninformed makes makes you
look very stupid tell me well a son of a
sorry you can beat this up you're a son
of a one second you're saying one second
he's saying look at this nons far
rhetoric they're having kids you know
Muslims have kids you bastard what are
you talking and he goes this 30,000
people this he goes this BS 30 30,000
people killed started by Hamas you
bastard who's killing 30,000 people who
who it's your country you scum and now
now this brother this brother what's
name bam he explains why those numbers
have increased you see this is how in
how how like when you watch that while
being uninformed makes me makes you look
very stupid tell me why tell me how tell
me how the population has gone 2 million
to 5 million yeah because most of the
1.5 extra million didn't come from Gaza
they were pushed away from other parts
of Israel so most of these people they
have increased because of refug if
you're talking about the settlers those
are tens of thousands millions of people
my wife family is not from Gaza and yet
they found themselves in Gaza because
they were sitting in other other cities
and Villages outside Gaza so funk you
he's explaining why those population
increased okay but what's the argument
let's say when Hitler was uh
Exterminating the Jewish Community yeah
okay and then I came and said well hold
on a second man yes we can't say this
genocide happening or whatever it's
happening um because you know what the
Jewish population has inreased in
different what's that got to do with
anything no no no no h is not committed
genocide why because the Jewish
population is increasing what's the
population increasing got to do with the
act of genocide genocide can happen look
30,000 kids have been killed no no no
but that's the point the point is that's
got no correlation with the actual topic
because what is Israel's whole argument
throughout we are trying to eradicate
Hamas okay no problem how much Hamas is
there in Gaza let's go on a larger
estimate let's say 50,000 Hamas on the
Gaz strip no problem okay 50,000 if
Israel was to continue L operate on the
Gaza Strip the way they have been with
the amount of innocent civilians that
have been killed they would end up
wiping out the population in order to
wipe out 50,000 Hamas yes like the ratio
is to 100 the ratio is absolutely
ridiculous and that is why you have
countries coming out South Africa coming
out I mean the IDF release you have you
have the IDF releasing a tweet yesterday
you know and they're showing that oh
they're showing like a like a voice
recording oh uh I think there's children
playing on the field Etc oh oh hold them
hold and I tweet I responded back I said
the fact that you're even tweeting
something like this why would you even
tweet something like this why like why
would you is it speaks volumes the fact
that you you would even tweet and speak
like this and try and defend your
positions Netanyahu came out it's
Collective punish yeah we had Netanyahu
coming out recently and it's the first
time ever it's the first time in in the
recent months that he's come out and
speaking in English addressing English
audiences and he's basically saying
we've always been targeting Hamas we've
always been doing this we we care about
the civilians we drop FL what on Earth
are you talking about we know from the
records that Israel has told people from
the north to move to the South and then
they have proceeded to bomb the South
yes that's exactly what's happened and
we know when during the ceasefire people
assumed the Palestinian assumed okay now
there's a ceasefire we can move towards
the north they start moving towards the
north to go and pick their things up
they're getting shot at by Israeli
snipers so and not only that you you you
basted then why did you mention amikit
huh why you metion Amite who's aites
like Moses was to ordered which we don't
believe to go and kill men women
children babies donkeys everyone that's
the amikit that you're talking about
come back yeah and that's that's also
been used in the icj by in the they're
using they're saying these people are
basically calling for outright ethnic
cleansing but let's carry on watching
this scumback this is the systemic
pushing of people from other parts of
Israel pushing them that's not millions
of people this is why I said that you're
intellectually dishonest intellectually
lazy that's not the cause of millions of
people I'm familiar with the S dis
talking these are people millions of
people the people who belong to Gaza are
700,000 people right now Gaza is 2.2
million that is not birth rate my friend
these are people pushed from and by the
way that's not the first time 1948 at
the night of the Declaration of the
state of Israel 1.5 million 1.5 million
Palestinians were like moved overnight
so it's not the first thing so before
you tell giving me numbers to you want
no what are behind the numbers because
these are not people giving in babies
these are people being pushed from other
places in order to be part of the open
air prison that it is okay so if you
want to fact check me let me fact check
you anytime that there's numbers
increasing BF going from 650 450
whatever you want to call it to 2
million however it happens that's the
exact opposite of a genocide so the
whole genocide the whole open air pring
points talking points of BS no and this
is why I said and he's saying basically
genocide is only happening if you WIP a
disproportion amount of people then it's
like genocide happening how about the
religious schools in Israel that
actually tell people that we should kill
all Arabs and these you know all those
Jews that are running around bombing
everywhere around the world no it
doesn't [__] exist it's only in Islam
really but talk about the Jews killing
the Palestinians inside I'm talking
about the around the world if I said
we're bad people are we bad people out
what I'm saying very what I'm saying
terorist religion we are a terrorist
religion take it out you said it your
you said it let's do it I mean like this
is like you have you have a really
interesting outlook for people who look
like me you look at me and I'm Muslim
and you you have all of these
assumptions about me being a terrorist
while is not a terrorist you said the
word you what's the difference between
teror they go on on like some Rogue
groups and they kill so so there's a
very interesting point here what's the
context of this conversation we're
speaking about Gaz right we're speaking
about the strip being bombed right we're
speaking about innocent women children
dying which even this guy he knows
that's that's the context of the
conversation and look at what he decides
to bring up in the context of that
conversation yeah he decides to bring up
oh your religion oh terrorism ohw AR
going so what are you saying say with
your chest what are you saying are you
basically saying so this all of this
justifies us doing the bombings that
we're doing on the Strip all of this
essentially you see when when we see
them speak and they're mentioning all of
these things what are you saying what
what are you trying to say like we saw
the icj we saw the Israeli one of the
Israeli Representatives come to the
stage and you know what he was saying he
was saying uh uh South Africa you you
know uh is Affiliated uh you know they
have affiliation with Hamas you know
after October 7th uh we had Hamas you
know officials travel to South Africa ET
what are you saying say what you believe
outright say I I believe South Africa is
representing Hamas and that's why we
have some ministers in Israel who for
some reason they become very very bold
and they actually do say it they say
this stupid ridiculous argument South
Africa we had one of the M ministers in
Israel say South Africa is the legal arm
for Hamas that is the level of logic
that these people have come to
ridiculous
anyone that's having basic Humanity
that's what they said to certain
journalists if you're being objective
you're supporting Hamas ridiculous it's
basic it's like people people are making
jokes like know the guy he lost his
papers now now we're at that level of
making just to justify to what what to
justify the bombing of innocent women
and children strip is home to majority
women and children that is what the
nature of the population of is so what
are you justifying by speaking like this
exactly and one thing that we need to
mentioned is very if you look at it that
he's talking about all these Muslims are
going what this this BS rhetoric that's
used by islamophobes you're an absolute
islamophobic bigot that's what you are
you're a flipping dirt bag who is even
blaming Hamas for the 30,000 people that
have been killed you have come to those
lands and stole it yes and you are
killing those innocent people you are
depriving them you're turning the water
off so many stuff and in the Westbank
Hamas doesn't exist but let me say you
something for those Muslims who have
carried out atrocities there's one thing
thing you see consistently with Muslims
we are morally consistent not
strategically because when Isis were
carrying out attacks I have confronted
Isis members or supporters indirectly
yes from lay man to public figures to
Muslim leaders to IMS unanimously bro
all the Muslims condemn the killing of
innocent people we have said this we
said these people are against our
religion but let me tell you something
but we see a very St uh a contrast when
it comes to this individual this guy is
a public figure yeah does he condemn
Israel no clearly not he's he's
justifying he's bringing oh terrorism oh
this one second that that woman I spoke
to a gen a woman who's just gone about
her business in the park I told her I
said Palestinian she said I do not
believe they are innocent exactly ex do
you believe do you accept that Israel
killed innocent Palestinian children I
don't think they're
innocent that's the thing I don't think
they're innocent I don't know what I
would say to people from the IDF to the
interior Ministry to to the defense
Ministry to the MP to the idea of
soldiers unanimously are saying what
that we should wipe out Gaza Muslims are
saying innocent people should not be
killed we condemn Isis and anyone for
that matter you've got these Zionist
consistently from all degrees all walks
of life un they are not innocent they
should be killed unbeliev that is what
we're going to end on is any last words
you like to say to the bastard here
who's going to watch it Adam you bastard
that's what you want I just want to tell
you to your face you are a flipping
bastard you have no shame that you do
not even condemn something you have to
be a human being it's good you know it's
good you know why because they just
you're just showing the world what you
are yes that's you're the whole world
the public opinion is changing I saw Ben
sh I saw Ben himself saying not he is he
was crapping himself because the studies
came out that shows that people are now
sympathizing with the Palestinians more
in America in America say why are we
funding Israel why we isra America comes
first that's all I have to say any other
last That's it man it was a
pleasure would you feel like see more
reaction videos from myself and M please
let us know till next
time please send this to that scumbag
inah goodbye